bonsoir
bonsoir le scénario c'est la colonne
vertébrale d'un film et la moelle
épinière que sont les actes et les
acteurs qui les acteurs qui en fait qui
sent la moelle épinière et que sans la
colonne vertébrale sept mois c'est la
moelle épinière que sont les acteurs ne
trouvera il ne trouvera elle ne saurait
pas où ce coût se situe pour se situer
le squelette
le squelette total d'un squelette global
le sol est d'un film qui en fait le
rallye
le réalisateur qui est le ce que le
squelette de ce film ne bénéficient pas
de cette moelle épinière et il ne
pourrait pas marcher à l'avant
alors les nommé pour le césar du
scénario original son noémie lvovsky
pour camille redouble
non vous pouvez pas ce que c'était super
sympa j'ai adoré c'est drôle c'est
émouvant c'est ces nostalgiques mais
c'est pas passéiste c'est samir guesmi
il est génial je savais que c'était
nominaux ski qui avait écrit le scénario
absolument fait à l'écrit elle joue doit
elle fait tout elle réalise et joue
dedans qui tâche c'est extraordinaire
michael haneke pour amour
ouais vous pouvez aussi parce que ça va
bouleverser sa c'est
non mais c'est ses deux bouts on sait où
on va on finit tous bons mais là c'est
poids trintignant empruntiez emmanuelle
riva et c'est extraordinaire ce qui lui
arrive c'est moi c'est bon je crois que
c'est mon pote à cacher jamais caché
caché la pianiste laurent pardon de vous
déranger mais enfin si vous pouviez nous
éviter tous ces commentaires un peu
neuneu quand même ça serait pareil
contre les grossièretés que vous m'avez
fait dire l'année dernière ça ça pose
pas de problème ça
non et je préférais je crois oui alors
moi je vous rappelle que je viens
d'intégrer la troupe de la
comédie-française et personne ne
l'ignorent oui merci et je ne
certains mots que je ne peux plus me
permettre de prononcer en public
ah oui lesquelles par exemple écouter ça
tombe très bien parce que justement je
m'étais fait une petite fiche pour être
sûrs de ne pas les prononcer alors
connard [ __ ] anus hors contexte
médical
[ __ ] grosse [ __ ] et en même temps je
ne vois pas pourquoi on vous ferait dire
grosse [ __ ] aux césar